july the 1st
2020 and one of the last big protests in
hong kong
a gathering held in defiance of social
distancing rules
and a sweeping new national security law
the same law
under which tong yin kit has now been
convicted
it was the day disobedience accelerated
these images capturing the moment tong
drove his motorcycle
towards a group of policemen attached to
his machine
a banner proclaiming liberate hong kong
revolution of our times
that was a cry heard constantly during
the unrest
tong had pleaded not guilty to both
charges on which he was convicted
his trial happened without a jury
instead the verdict
was delivered by a panel of three judges
appointed by hong kong's chief executive
carrie lam
the reasons the judge gave for their
verdict runs to more than 60 pages
but in essence they say that tong fully
understood
that the words on his protest banner
equated to a call
for independence and that the slogan was
capable of inciting others
he'll be sentenced at a later date but
faces a life term
more than 120 people have so far been
charged under the national security
legislation
including the publisher jimmy ly who was
also in court on tuesday
like tong he too faces spending the rest
of his life
in jail adrian brown al jazeera hong
kong